it used to be that um
i would say after world war ii there was
a very very strong impulse in america
and across europe to say look liberalism
is all we it's all we need people you
know private people will make the
decisions
about you know
where the guard rails should be what the
constraints should be
and i uh you know it
maybe that made sense to a lot of people
then i think at this point we've reached
the point where you know we're looking
across america american across europe
and i i think
i mean i think it's scary i think i
think you can see the chaos
coming
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
one of the founders of the national
conservatism conference president of the
herzl institute in jerusalem and author
of the brand new book conservatism of
rediscovery yoram hazoni welcome back to
the reuben report
hi dave thanks for having me back
it's good to see you my friend i sense
by that background you are not in the
holy land but perhaps a slightly less
holy land at the moment
i'm here in dc i i actually wanted to be
with you in florida but you guys didn't
have like room in the studio for me or
something so
so i'm in dc
it's a very we've been very busy i just
got back from tour you're on the short
list of people i would have been willing
to have here at the house but let's dive
right into the book because first off
i've got it in my hand this is a this is
a dense powerful book full of a whole
bunch of the ideas that you've been
talking about for really decades at this
point but i want to read just the first
paragraph off the back flap here because
i think you say something very
interesting that i think is the thing
that sort of connects both of us you say
conservatism as we know it has failed
while liberalism was eroding the
foundations of our culture the family
the nation and religion
conservative conservatives adopted the
very principles that ensured their
defeat
routinely confused with classical
liberalism conservatism found itself
defenseless before a ferocious
and relentless foe all right now you
know i'm mr classical liberal
i i think i helped bring that phrase
back into the american lexicon but you
also know that i have found faults
within the the liberal lens uh we've
discussed them before and we've
discussed them at nat con actually just
a couple months back here in florida
um so
what brings you
well first let me let you define
conservatism and how it's different than
classical liberalism and then we'll go
from there
okay
conservatism puts
conservatism's a an anglo an
anglo-american political tradition it
goes goes back many centuries long
before burke
and it's a tradition that puts
um puts the the idea of transmission and
stability of the nation at at the center
so a conservative is always going to be
asking questions like
have we
uh upheld the you know the the main
principles traditions that are holding
our people together you know that that
can't go on forever there's always
deterioration there's always things that
change and then a conservative is going
to be looking back when you know when
when something starts to fall apart
um and saying
what can we restore
what what can we go back to
that used to work that we really need
and are sorry that we've lost
so i think a lot of people are hearing
that and that's pretty clean and clear
that you know there were some
hard-fought things of the past that we
should remember and perhaps bring back
into our daily lives
does classical liberalism not
grab a hold of all of that what's the
what's the problem there
well classical liberalism is something
that
um is based on like if you take a look
at the you know like the big thinkers of
of of the enlightenment the rationalist
thinkers of the enlightenment who
uh who originally designed this
uh liberal
liberalism is a it's a it's a set of
principles that begin with uh every
every human being is by nature free and
perfectly free and perfectly equal
and uh the the purpose of government is
to
is to give the individual to to protect
the the rights and equalities that
belong to the individual by nature
so the the entire set of ideas that you
know they're at the basis of liberalism
uh they're they're basically you know
lots of people said this they're
basically they are a philosophy of
freedom they're very
a a way of thinking about um
how how do we work it so that people are
maximally
free and unconstrained
and the problem is and this is i i mean
this is
this is something very deep and very
serious that i really think we need to
be talking about
much more
is that
human beings do not only need freedom by
nature and
if you think human beings only need
freedom then then i think you've got a
mistaken and misleading philosophy human
beings need to be constrained they they
they need to have
guard rails and guidelines
they need to to
to to be encouraged to do
um the things that are needed in order
to keep their their society their people
their families
to keep it going
and uh it used to be that um
i i would say after world war ii there
was a very very strong impulse in
america and across europe to say look
liberalism is all we it's all we need
people you know private people will make
the decisions
about you know
where the guard rails should be what the
constraints should be
and i uh you know it
maybe that made sense to a lot of people
then i think at this point we've reached
the point where you know we're looking
across american across europe and i i
think
i mean i think it's scary i think i i
think you can see the chaos
coming
the the uh people the the assumption of
liberalism is let people argue and uh
and be free freely speak and freely
argue and they'll come to the right
decisions
but i would say when you know since 2020
we're looking at an america that is
um is just it's tottering on having
uh you know the the woke neo-marxist
ideology become kind of like the public
the public ideology of of the state
and if you look you know sort of on on
the edges of the political right like
beyond conservatism
i i there's
fast-growing
um
thinkers i mean
that a lot of the kids are reading uh
who are arguing for dictatorship they're
just saying look the whole the whole
idea of you know the american
constitution has failed and uh and
they're looking to dictatorship
so
i think it's becoming really really
clear
that if we don't start talking about
conservation and transmission and
restoration like a lot and focusing on
it
i i
i think america is in danger and i think
it's in danger of taking like all the
democratic countries with it all right
so you're hitting on a lot of the stuff
that obviously i focus on and i'm proud
to say that at the end of my first book
don't burn this book i made an argument
related to god and belief connecting
some of the classic liberal beliefs uh
to that because i i saw
what you're now talking about i sort of
saw it on the horizon that we could get
to this point so first do you think is
that a flaw in liberalism or is that a
flaw in in human nature or is that or is
there there even a distinction there in
that from say world war ii till about
i don't know maybe five ten years ago
the liberal order sort of worked right
or i don't want to put words in your
mouth in my estimation it sort of worked
and then suddenly this woke uh parasite
got inside but would you say that it
roughly worked for a certain amount of
decades
well i i think it's been running down i
i i
look i think i think 2020 was a shocking
was a shocking year in terms of you know
just
institutions all the way you know from
the new york times to princeton
university just
being taken over i think it was a
shocking year and i i don't want to say
that like you know
there was obvious that was going to
happen
but i think as i i write in in this new
book i think i think the deterioration
has been
uh
really clear
you know almost a straight line since
you know since the 1960s
uh even the 1940s
by 1960s is when
uh is uh is when there's this final
decision that the united states is going
to ban
god religious tradition
prayer bible just ban it outright more
or less from you know from schools
across the country
and
the the theory behind it was was people
said look our our country it's it are we
live in a christian country you know
overwhelming majority of people are
christian we can be you know tolerant
and decent to other people but basically
it's a christian country so we we don't
have to have this stuff in the schools
and um i i think pretty much since then
um
the the the assumption that you could
just take
god in scripture out of the schools
and it would continue to live like you
know on sundays and in people's homes i
i think that turned out not to be true
and what happened is
uh first in the name of equality
um you know and
freedom from religion and and everybody
being treated equal
all religion was removed from the
schools
god in scripture and after that
um
then uh
you know the the the idea of an
independent nation or of the family
ended up kind of being eliminated from
the schools
and
by this point you even you know even the
idea of man and woman being you know the
the the basis of the traditional family
that's also now in the name of equality
and freedom from religion
that's also been eliminated so i
as i understand it um
it's a
it's been a one-way ratchet where you
know every every 10 years something else
that you know that we will sorely miss
has been
uh
removed and and and
you know
people just don't
don't know what to do with it i mean i i
really think an awful lot of people uh
in in america and other countries are
saying look this is just the fall of the
roman empire this is just the end
like you you can't you just
you can't remove every single basic
building block of the way we built
society
throw it away open it to question and
and then think that there's going to be
anything but chaos and
that's that's pretty much what looks
like it's coming
right chaos seems to be at our doorstep
so do you think secular institutions
simply cannot work
at all i mean
basically what you're saying is there
well i guess everything is going to
degrade over time right
everything degrades over time the ques
the the question is are are you
helping it degrade or are you working
for a restoration where you can see that
you know a mistake has been made so you
can you can act to try to stop it look
dave i i'm i'm i'm a religious person in
the end
um i you know in the end i think uh
we have to do what looks right to us the
best we can in the end we're really bad
at seeing the future and what's going to
happen is going to you know god decides
in the end what's going to come of all
of our efforts but we have an obligation
to to try to restore things you know to
try to restore uh respect for the uh
american constitution and the
anglo-american
legal tradition we have to try to
restore respect for the traditional
family and for uh for the bible and for
god
that's up to us to try to do and you
know maybe it'll work
so i think a certain amount of people
are watching this and what they may not
know is uh on the other side of that
very fine head of hair my friend is is a
yarmulke back there you are an orthodox
jew you live you live in jerusalem uh
and yet here you are talking about anglo
beliefs uh christian america things like
that uh i was on a panel with you at
natcon where we were trying to sort of
work out it was it was the two of us and
sora bamari who i've had on the show and
douglas murray who i've had on many
times trying to sort of
whittle out where if you were to go back
to some of what you're calling for in a
national conservative country
what happens to the minorities what
happens to the religious minorities what
happens to people that don't necessarily
prescribe to all of the sort of
religious set of views that you're
including here so what do we do with
that
okay well the the book deals with
two different fronts okay one one is the
question you're asking me now which is
uh about you know the public life
of
of the country and the other the other
part of the book deals with you know
with our private lives and because
people tend to think these things are
unrelated i think they're
deeply connected and so the the book is
really an argument for people to
uh to drop the idea that you can just
argue for conservative policy i i think
that you have to also lead a
conservative life you have to uh come
back to a conservative life and be a
conservative person so they're there are
those two things now when when i talk
about conservative democracy
i'm talking about a democracy right i'm
talking about you know the kind of
democracy that uh that america was
um
sure there's some things from the past
that we should never go back to i mean
you know slavery and persecution of uh
blacks in america just as like the most
obvious example i i don't know any
conservative that wants to go back to
that in fact the in my book i make the
argument that that was a
deviation from the anglo-american
tradition which is you know for a very
long time was anti-slavery before there
were slaves in america
but um but since i'm arguing for
democracy i'm i'm still talking about
the the political framework
where this should not be imposed on
anybody we're talking about
um
those states that still have a christian
majority you know or let's say i mean
maybe there's uh orthodox jews who would
uh support this kind of thing
or others so those those states those
regions those places
where there's still a desire to lead a
uh a democratic life but where the
public the the the public philosophy
let's say
is is not neo-marxism the public
philosophy is going to be based on a
biblical vision on a on on a christian
and and jewish vision
and i'm my my assumption is that um that
anybody who actually
wants to do this i'm not just assuming
it i mean this is what i you know i i i
talk to catholics and protestants and
jews this i mean i i i talk to them and
try to understand people from all over
the country what what's possible
and um i i believe that there is a
uh that people looking at sort of the
cliff that that were you know that
america is just hurtling towards this
cliff and about to go over i i think an
awful lot of people
protestants catholics and jews and
others
would be
willing to negotiate some kind of a
a
return of
let's say the
the basic christian moral vision to be
like the public background against which
uh things are are operate in some places
i mean in some some states in the us and
i think
the conservative way to do this is you
know not to have uh the supreme court
you know dictate this to people who
don't want it the conservative way to do
it is to experiment with it in those
places that want it so that we can see
what is this you know what does this add
up to instead of like you know saying
well you know
christians were always terrible
throughout their history let's see what
the chris which i don't believe by the
way but instead of that kind of like you
know argument in the air we should do an
experiment let's see let let's see what
you know
what does a what are the christians
in america when they get to be like the
public culture in uh in in a few states
what do they do if
if it's better and i i'm guessing it's
going to be better if it's better so
people want to move there and other
states will adopt it and and if it's you
know as terrible as you know everybody's
always saying to to let the you know to
to let the christians where they're a
majority to have that let them have the
public if it's so awful so we'll see
that it's awful and we'll say okay we
tried that that didn't work let's do
something else
so do you see something like what's
going on here in florida where i think
we're defending almost everything you're
talking about but not from the religious
perspective in that the governor is not
up there talking about this stuff from a
religious perspective however he's doing
a lot of the work that i think you're
calling for he is acknowledging
differences biologically between boys
and girls and getting rid of critical
race theory out of the schools and he's
fighting against the constantly
overreaching federal government all
those things
i think i sense that you still think
that that may not be enough for the
experiment as you want it is that right
no i i i don't think it's enough because
i i mean
the basic problem is that
you know for for many years
most
uh most liberal you know scholars and
professors who talked about this kind of
thing
theorists um they talked about
liberalism as a neutral state like a a
state that wouldn't actually have any
kind of moral vision it would just be
neutral and let everybody do what they
want and
this book argues and i i mean i'm
certainly not the only one but i'm
arguing there is no such thing as a
neutral state like you could you can try
it but it it it just it continues to be
mostly you know mostly christian values
up until the moment that it just falls
apart and you suddenly realize that it's
you know it's anti-christian and i think
that's what's happening you know that
that's what's happening in america and
in in britain and other places too is
that um there
there is a public philosophy but that
public philosophy is progressive woke
neo-marxism
and
i i i know that there are a lot of good
liberals
who um
they want to hold on to the idea
of well let's just go back to a neutral
state
and i i think they just don't understand
that
that that co that's collapsed and the it
hasn't collapsed by ac by accident it's
collapsed because of the fact that
when you're saying no the state is
neutral we don't have to defend any
particular set of values when you say
that then you just open the door for the
marxist to take over the only way you
can fight like a a serious uh uh public
religion or public philosophy is with
another public philosophy and uh
so
right so i get it i get you on the on
the liberal part i say you know i talk
about bill maher all the time where the
five remaining sane liberals in america
they just are sort of in this slow
motion paralysis and two years later
they get it they repeat what a bunch of
us say but they keep voting for the
wrong people so i'm with you on that but
what would you say is it is not enough
for say what ron desantis is doing in
florida i mean i can tell you from
living here for four months i'm living
in a a free state that feels strong and
defended and
it is starkly different than california
which made all of the wrong decisions
and went that route
well i i think the number one thing
is that
sending kids to schools
where
uh five days a week or or whatever it is
they
they spend their time in an environment
that is
um stripped of any reference to
god or to the bible is the basis of
of western
civilization the bible is the
the the fundamental text on on on which
western tradition was built i i i think
that that doesn't work because
and i
i i try to go into the uh into the
psychology of all of this and and you
know how how it actually works because i
think people don't don't understand this
if if you want anything
right you know
young people are always saying what do
you mean conservative conservatives
don't conserve anything right you've
heard that i mean people say that all
the time is like like what have
conservatives succeeded in conserving in
the you know in the last 50 years
and i think we have to take that
argument seriously that
there's a constant rolling cultural
revolution and the reason for the
constant rolling cultural revolution
which just rips up one thing after
another is because of the fact nobody
nobody's focused on how how do how does
the transmission the conservation of
ideas actually work
and for it the way it actually works
is that
if you're a kid
and you see that people give that the
people around you give honor to
something like
let's say the bible they they give honor
to it what do you mean they say look
this is really important now i'm not
talking about you know
them saying you have to believe this or
if you don't believe this then you're a
terrible person well i'm talking about
something much more basic
that if you're an environment where
people are giving honor they say look
this constitution is you know the the
the best that you know that that there's
been in the world and this scripture
is the the best moral framework for
leading your life that there's ever been
when you hear that from
people you respect your mind opens up
right everybody's always saying oh your
mind closes i that's not my experience
if people are saying look this is just
really important you should take a look
at it
your mind opens up to learning
and right now in in america and lots of
other places i mean this is true for
most of you of this true from most
democratic countries
the kids they're the kids the adults
people's brains are snapped shut like a
trap somebody starts talking about bible
and and they they think oh that's that
primitive dark ages stuff that you know
that
that we got rid of people people are
scared of it people are are you know
they just think it's like you you must
be some kind of idiot for talking about
this stuff and as long as
the
the
the bible continues to be under this
shadow instead of being
this spectacular document that created
the world we live in
instead of that people just keep saying
oh that's the dark ages
so the the the disintegration of what
used to be america
uh
like it it's inevitable you you you
pulled all of the you know the vacuum
tubes out of the back of the television
i mean that's like i'm dating myself you
put you pulled all the tran you sorry
about the hdmi wire right right you
pulled right you pulled right you pulled
all the tr the the the the the red and
the yellow
yeah you know the
the little square things in the back you
pulled them out you stepped on them you
you get what i'm saying so and then
you're surprised the thing stops working
so you got to get it working again and
to get it working again we need to be
able to give honor to those things that
allowed our ancestors to to create a
free and constrained and decent society
so i hate to keep bringing this back to
florida but you know that it's really
just on my mind these days and i'm i'm
so impressed with what's going on here
so i think i sense what you're saying is
basically
florida is doing a pretty darn good job
you'd like to see the reinstitution of
some religious teaching in school you do
make a carve out for let's say the the
non-believers or people of minority
religions et cetera et cetera
but but is that it is i mean is that
basically the only thing that you think
is going wrong because to me what's
happening here right now at a secular
level and and i don't even think it's
purely at a secular level desantis
doesn't talk about religion a lot as far
as i know but he's talking about reality
and i think his reality is based in
something
yeah i i i'm look i i i don't want to
look i i like desantis and i like what
he's doing
but i i think that what's what what's
sort of missing from the conversation is
is a
is a longer view mm-hmm that's kind of
happening because because because
everything that's going on
right now is
is mostly reactive
it's reacting against the excesses of uh
of of of woke neo marxism and god bless
him for doing that and and the
legislature and you know and chris ruffo
and all the people who are working at
the grassroots level god bless them and
they they really are trying to save
their country and and i hope they
succeed but
you know we're at the very very
beginning of this
and what's actually going to happen
is uh as
um
as christian activists like
like roofo
start to
you know get
just look beyond
um just reacting and trying to like like
like
try to get the worst of the stuff out of
the schools
you're gonna find out that that's not
enough to transmit anything it it it's
just not i mean the
the schools without the woke stuff
from 15 years ago that's how we got here
right in other words
the way that we got to the mess that
we're in now is that 15 and 20 years ago
everything was run by liberals
and and so i'm i'm just trying to look
just a little bit beyond the horizon and
i i no i don't i don't think it's just a
matter of
of education but i i don't want to speak
for i look i i think there's going to be
a number of different different states
and countries and they're going to try
different things
so
some of those things could be um you
know
the
uh the they could be sabbath laws you know
some people might want to try out
might want to try having sabbath laws
they could be
um uh
uh
legislation about what the family is
they could be legislation about abortion
i mean it could be all sorts of things
um and i think a smart governor
or or leader what what he would do is he
would say look i i don't want to take
the most controversial stuff and like
try to force it on people that i mean
that that's just not smart leadership i
i think that in every state what'll
happen is
uh conservative leadership will
will say
what are the kinds of things that you
know that we have a majority and they
can get behind this and and they they
think that this could make sense
and they'll try different things and and
they'll they'll you know they'll see
what what can work and they'll do
experiments
so with your argument let's say they do
this in alabama would your argument then
be well you're in the free united states
that then if you don't like what's going
on there whether it's sabbath laws or
whether it's related to the traditional
family and i do want to obviously
discuss a little more on that right that
you should just get up and get going to
california
yeah why not
i mean look if you want to know why
uh why
there are borders like why do we divide
the world up into into countries and
states and municipalities with borders
the reason we do that is because we
assume if we're not like if we're not
totally insane then we assume that the
local people close to the ground they
that they have they know what their
people can you know uh want and what
they can put up with and and and what's
best for them that's obviously not
always true but it's more likely to be
true than some you know some distant
emperor who's like dictating everything
to everybody right so this is very much
what your first book was about by the
way right right so
so so that's the reason we have borders
now america was uh you know was founded
as a federal republic
and that federalism has you know
basically since world war ii it's been
progressive progressively ruined the
the the the fed the national supreme
court takes away the right of the
different states to you know to do any
kind of experimentation on major things
on major issues
and so
part of the part of the program
is you know has to be federalism it i
mean it has to be
giving
power back to people to try things at
the local level
and uh and
look i mean you know i
nobody ever you know thinks that
everything that their government is
doing is the way that they would do it i
mean you know
government is always some somebody else
and not only that but it's always like a
combination even even if you're in
government it's a compromise and it's a
combination of things but the bottom
line answer is
instead of having the national
government impose
what right you know one system on
everybody let's go back to
you know to to uh the the old federalism
and um let some of these these issues
which are just tearing america apart
let some of them be worked on on at
at the state level at the local level
and you know
i i there's some chance that people will
hate each other less
if they can say you know
look i i didn't like it in alabama so i
moved to massachusetts
look i can i can tell you as someone
that left california i
don't really care that much about
california anymore that's not to say
that there aren't good people that live
there of course there are i still have a
couple friends that haven't made the
move yet california is a beautiful place
but unfortunately the the political
leadership has chosen its uh its
direction and i just don't want that
much to do with it at this point and
they shouldn't have that much to do with
me as a citizen of the free state of
florida so
before we get into some of the granular
stuff on that um has there ever been a
time in the world where a country or a
group of people got so close to the
precipice got so close to that
chasm
that bottomless pit and then turned back
or is it just entropy that almost has to
take us over at this point
no look
there are forces of entropy that's for
sure um
but and and uh even successful
successful traditions like you know i i
know two traditions really well i know i
i pretty well i i i know the jewish
tradition which is like three 000 years
old and i know this anglo-american
tradition which is about a thousand
years old and what's really clear when
you study these long traditions
is that they run down
and then you know like like a great
there's a like a restoration there's
like a a a great man or a group of great
people who who who say we see the
precipice come coming and we got it we
got to restore it we got to put it back
together again
um you know just just two two two
obvious examples um uh in uh in english
history and people know that there were
i think most people probably know that
that in in the 1600s 1640s there was a a
a a a revolution a republican revolution
that killed the king and they they tried
to have republican a a republican like a
to revise the english constitution that
went on for i don't know 15 years or
something
and uh
and and and it didn't work it didn't
work it was it that they kept changing
the constitution they couldn't get any
kind of like like uh um
uh um
cohesive solidity back to their country
and
less than 20 years 20 years went by this
guy matthew hale who's like a a famous
conservative thinker who's in my book he
proposed let's let's bring let's bring
the king back and they brought the king
back and the the uh
the settlement that they ended up with
was a uh was a more moderate
constitutional monarchy than what they
had before
um
an example that's closer to you know to
to americans
is uh the the american constitution of
1787. you know people think of of and i
write about this at some length in in in
the new book people think of the
american constitution like you know like
they declared independence and they
wrote the constitution there was like
this miracle and and then they just got
it right but that's not what happened
that's almost the opposite of what
happened what actually happened is that
in 1777
the the uh the uh
americans tried to step away from the
anglo tradition they wrote a
constitution which is called the
articles of the confederation is what we
call it today but it was a constitution
and george washington and his forces
tried to fight a war against britain
under that constitution it was a weak
constitution its purpose was was liberty
its purpose was to give as much freedom
as possible
but
it it didn't give
the anybody enough strength to be able
to do things like like
raising an army
raising taxes
being able to impose you know a
negotiated treaty with another country
being imposed able to impose on the
states uh the terms of the treaty
and after 11 years of this chaos i mean
the where where
the american the the american army was
moved to georgetown by by people writing
personal checks as a donation
because the country was so weak
and washington came out of this and he
said
we we need something like like the
english government like the british
government we need some kind of strong
central government that that protects
freedom but it has the ability to raise
an army raise taxes
impose decisions where necessary
and that's how that's how the american
constitution was born it's a restoration
of the constitutional tradition of
anglo-americans and that restoration was
because they thought we're going over
the precipice if you just think for one
second like
if they hadn't been able to get private
donations to get the army to yorktown i
i mean they just could have lost the war
it's interesting because i've been
saying on my show for a couple weeks now
that we've we've begun to enter a
post-woke world i do see a fight
against
the the woke movement the the marxism
that you're talking about and you're
talking about checks being sent uh to
keep the army going and you know elon
musk buy in twitter uh one federal judge
reversing the mask mandate individual
people trying for that restoration is is
an interesting is the most american
thing perhaps that you could possibly do
so let's let's link this to something a
little more recent so at the national
conservatism conference which was at the
end of october
2021
you me sora bamari who i mentioned
earlier and douglas murray were all on a
panel where we were trying to do just
what we've been discussing here uh yeah
we were trying to piece together how do
you take the traditional sort of
religious conservative perspective
where do you blend that with the
classical liberal perspective how do you
take a purely secular libertarian and
the more tr even the more traditional
conservative how do you take all of this
combine all of these people with all of
their difference make it into something
that's whole and what was particularly
interesting about the conversation which
we'll we'll link to below so people can
see it is that two of the four panelists
up there happen to be gay now that
obviously is a
minority from a sexuality perspective
let's say um and we were really trying
to hash through these issues in about an
hour and a half talk and nothing was
left on the table and we took questions
from everybody
where do you see that now and i don't
know that i don't think we all got to a
full conclusion on it exactly i think
sorob and douglas definitely had some
big disagreements by the end but where
do you fall on that look i i i'm i'm
glad that we did the experiment
and and not only that but i i i'd like
to keep trying to do the experiment
because i
because i i think the reality is that um
that
there's all these
liberal refugees who are you know
they're they're moving to the right
because they they can see something
terrible is happening happening on the
left
and um these
you know and elon musk i don't know if
you saw i mean he he tweeted this you
know this this i saw it we write it on
the show right so he so i think a lot of
people feel like that he he says look
i've never been anything but a liberal
but but now i'm clearly on the right
it's not that i've moved but the
spectrum has moved it's being pulled
like taffy by the revolutionaries and so
he he sees himself now as being part of
the right
but
look
that's what's happening and what that
means is
we have no choice there's going to have
to be some kind of alliance between
conservative and liberals
but you know that doesn't mean that this
is easy to do and um and and and i don't
look i don't i i don't think that
particular thing worked out so well i
mean so uh douglas came out of it and uh
and he he felt like he needed to write
like an essay saying you know these
these these conservatives uh the they're
too much they're too far you know you
i don't know if you saw that but he like
like two weeks after he yeah i i've had
douglas on my show since right so we
discussed yeah okay so so so that was
him and then saurabh responded to him by
saying
i i just don't see how this can work
and
look i'm not you know i'm not like you
know
terribly surprised but
um
but that tension that you're talking
about
i get it exists and that's why i mean
for years i've been saying if there is
some sort of new conservative movement
on the horizon i still no matter what at
the end of the day will probably end up
on the more libertarian side of it or
classically liberal side of it i think
we're all trying to do something that's
that's tough and when you try to do
something that's tough or as jordan
peterson would say when we were on tour
all the time you know that that healthy
tension that perhaps we all want between
liberalism and conservatism it's hard to
balance that all the time and um
maybe it can't maybe it just can't be
done maybe it can't be done at a
national level i think perhaps it could
be done at a at a personal level
i think
you're you're a model in what you just
said right that that people can disagree
and in the end of the day we ought to be
able to just go have scotch together and
i i do everything i can
to to live like that myself and and and
i in in that i'm you know i'm following
you know the way that you talk to people
in the studio i mean i i i really think
that this uh that discussion should be
uh uh
amicable between people who are like you
know we're not we're not enemies we
we're friends who have important
disagreements and by the way removing
removing me from the equation if there's
a conservative out there a religious
conservative who thinks that douglas
murray is not a good enough conservative
for them then that's not my brand of
conservatism how about that
to remove us from the equation for a
moment you know well
douglas is look i i
douglas is a little bit different
because
douglas doesn't doesn't claim to be a
conservative he doesn't claim to be a
nationalist you know like he comes to he
comes to the conferences and uh and and
he says things like you know i probably
agree with one third of the things that
are being stated here so he he deflates
you know he participates he's a great
friend he's a he he participates fully
but but he he doesn't
um
he he he doesn't take a leadership
role among conservatives the way that
you do and i'm not blaming you for this
i mean i think everybody
everybody has just been really happy to
have somebody like you taking leadership
and i i i
i think it i think it's hit a bump and i
don't you know
i i i regret that i'm really sorry about
that but i'm looking forward to the
scotch yeah
listen i probably can't solve all of the
uh existential issues for all of the
people that come at this from a purely
religious perspective and i think it's a
great challenge to
you know blend a society from a
traditional and religious perspective
that also has an awful lot of secular
people
in it although you happen to be in the
swamp right now you live in a country
that's only you know 70 plus years old
that has done a pretty good job but
often an imperfect job of blending uh
the secular and the traditional and uh i
suppose the best thing we can do is
continue to have these conversations
right
you're um right the book
is conservatism a rediscovery and we
will do that whiskey and or tequila soon
my friend good seeing you okay
thank you dave good to see you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell